Let's talk a little bit about green tea because some people go, well, I saw your video on
EGCG, which is the Catechid in green tea extract that's beneficial for cancer and
decrease in IL-6 levels and different inflammation pathways and helping bone growth and all these
kind of things, all these great wonderful research articles on green tea extracted EGCG.
So people think, well, I'm just going to have a couple cups of green tea every day. I like the
taste of it and it's good. I mean, literally, if you're going to do therapeutic doses of EGCG
to get the benefits for cancer and for a decrease in inflammatory pathways, you'd have to do like
50 cups of green tea. So it's not really available just through the tea itself. You have to use
the concentrated Catechid extract to get the benefits. So you have to take a capsule
of some sort of green tea and then you go back to what the question started off with
is how do you trust the source that it's not toxic? Well, you have to know the company that you're
getting it from and that they're doing heavy metal testing on it. So let's go ahead.
You sell green tea extract supplement. So our green tea extract is called EGCG,
it's called clear EGCG because EGCG is the Catechid in green tea that you want.
Hey, there's other, there's so there's a number of good companies that have every kind of unmute
you're coming to Chaffee like a bad cell phone call. So I missed some of what you said about the
EGC like to get it in as a supplement to treat that. Sure. So EGCG, you need to take it as a supplement
not as a tea. In order to get the concentration of EGCG that you need, you have to take it as a
supplement. You're not going to get enough EGCG out of a green tea drink to give you really any
therapeutic benefits. You said you have it. You have a product that would suffice where we would
take water to a band network. Yeah. So the product we have is called clear EGCG,
clear EGCG. So if you search in the store it's called clear EGCG.